en 2008 la france découvre le visage du
trader jérôme kerviel fraudeur présumé
mis à pied dimanche dernier d'un trader
de 31 ans l'homme qui a fait perdre près
de cinq milliards d'euros à la société
générale et six ans plus tard voilà le
grand méchant loup de la finance à la
fête de l'huma de l'incarnation de la
folie des marchés aux combattants anti
finance tout au long de ces procès face
à la société générale jérôme kerviel a
habilement travail et sa communication
que je vis un cauchemar que j'ai encore
un peu de mal à réaliser
à un mois de son procès contre la
société générale en 2010 jérôme kerviel
est invité sur le plateau de laurent
delahousse
on nous a traités de terroristes
tesla de faux et jérôme kerviel sur
conseil de ses communicants et de son
avocat joue la carte de la force
tranquille voici ses mots clés je
travaille énormément son dossier et
sinon ça va bien je suis très confiant
pour mon procès je suis serein et je
l'attends avec impatience mon 3 cet
autre rendez-vous avec la justice en
il revient alors sous les lumières
auprès du pape françois celui qui a
dénoncé la tyrannie de la finance je me
suis pris une énorme baffe
avec cette rencontre avec le pape dans
son discours aujourd'hui le pape dénonce
la tyrannie les marchés financiers la
finance et et c'est quelque chose que
nous savons que j'ai envie de porter
aussi et dont j'ai envie de me laver le
chemin de la rédemption
il arpente entre rome et paris parfois
rejoints par des personnalités des
soutiens et surtout par les caméras
parmi les compagnons de route des
religieux je défends la personne de
jérôme ce qui lui est arrivé est injuste
et des politiques essentiellement du
front de gauche en septembre 2014 tout
juste libéré sous surveillance
électronique nouveau coup de com
jean luc mélenchon invite l'ex trader à
la fête de l'huma et vous narrer ce
qu'on lui dit à la banque qui reviennent
fraudeur puis apaisé repentis et enfin
kerviel politique une image d image
façonnée par plusieurs communicants qui
ont en partie réconcilier les français
avec l'ex trader en 2015 ils étaient 53
% à avoir une opinion favorable de
jérôme kerviel
[Musique]